In our rapidly developing
world, the demand
for well-educated workers
has never been greater.
Yet for many, education
remains out of reach.
Worldwide 250 million
children are out of school.
Even more are unable to
read, write, or count.
Every day a growing
displaced population
abandons their
education, and others
struggle to find new
modes of education
to balance work with learning.
At the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology,
we believe everyone
should have access
to a quality education
and a better tomorrow.
To help make that a reality,
MIT and Community Jameel
are launching the Abdul
Latif Jameel World Education
Laboratory or J-WEL.
Our mission: to bring
together the best minds
to transform education
and learning worldwide,
from pre-kindergarten through
higher education to workforce
training.
MIT has been a pioneer in the
field of digital learning,
opening our doors to the world
through OpenCourseWare, MITx,
edX, and most recently, the
MicroMasters Credential.
Join us now, as MIT and J-WEL
explore education across
cultures, backgrounds, and ages,
and collaborate with educators,
universities,
governments, nonprofits,
and industries to find new
solutions in every area
of education - from research
on learning and curriculum
development, to teacher
education and public policy.
Our goal: to confront the
most pressing problems facing
education today and deliver
sustainable, scalable,
impactful solutions
to the world.
As we transform learning,
we transform lives.
Together, let's
learn how, and do it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]